let's go brandon what's up no i'm not
much rich what about you oh hey man i'm
happy to have you on appreciate
so yeah uh
i've been watching
your kind of content for a few years and
so my question would be is i recently
got involved with a single mom i'm a
single dad
her her child's 10 female my child's a
10 year old girl as well okay i just
want to like take you know what's your
take on it should i just like keep it
moving or
you know maybe take you know consider
this woman is you know a serious option
how old are you i'm 34.
and
like what's the plan like are you
looking for a girlfriend a wife like
what are you trying to do here you you
looking to have more kids yeah ideally
i'm looking for a a wife
you know uh and then have more kids and
see that's you know
you know kind of mention that to this
woman and she seems pretty
i'd say
you know unusually
uh
down to earth in the sense of like i
have a decent net worth and she's
already like would you make you need to
make sure you get a prenup or whatever
so she's
you know already you know kind of even
said like in the event
like prenup
how old is she
she's 29.
okay have you read my book i have not
there's a chapter in my book on single
moms okay okay you should get it's on
amazon or you can just listen to it as
an audible
um i can't go over the whole thing with
you but
what i would recommend you do is you
look at the chapter on red flags i mean
read the whole damn book obviously but
the chapter in red flags will help you
uh get some clarity on whether or not
this is a check you want to spend any
time with on a long term basis and
the one thing that i will say is in the
chapter on dealing with single moms i
discourage it generally speaking with
the exception
that you've got a kid that's the same
age and sex as her kid so you've got a
daughter that's 10 she's got a daughter
that's 10 you're not going to have any
kind of risk factor i'm assuming they
can get along fine sort of thing
so there's that element to consider but
generally speaking i tell guys to stay
away from single moms right because
it's it it usually boils down to the
juice not being worth the squeeze
so i'd recommend reading that i can't
like i got to know a lot about you know
what's going on how long you've been
dating her like how long you guys been
together
uh see this about three weeks and see
that's what i told her three weeks dude
yeah i told her i was like hey i'm gonna
have to see other people while i
determine whether or not this is gonna
be something i wanna do okay and she's
like well i don't know if i how i feel
about that what not and i was just like
well
why are you telling her that you're
seeing other women why just to be you
know i'm a very open honest upfront kind
of guy and like two like i did like i
said i mentioned that i have a decent
net worth and like i know
in the sense of like i understand women
well enough to know that women are
looking for a man that has the ability
to provide and i have that ability to
provide so i know i'm not well that also
makes you a target then that also makes
you a guy that has the ability to to
to hand over half of his yeah you
know if she's cunning and creative
enough too right
um
so
so this woman you've only known her for
three weeks you haven't met her kids
your kids haven't hung out like you
don't even know her basically right
yeah
what you're saying is what you should do
but you shouldn't say and i'm going to
explain that to you so what you're
talking about is spinning plates right
are you familiar with the concept i've
heard it you guys say it a few times
yeah so i mean you're just dating
multiple women in a non-monogamous
fashion just trying to you know figure
out you know what your options look like
and get your head around what's out
there right so
when you do that you just go about doing
it you don't openly declare
hey i'm seeing other women you just go
about it now at some point she's going
to probably say hey brandon i really dig
your vibe where do we stand
um you might be standing at the front
door thinking yourself well do i tell
her i see myself standing at the front
door seeing you off or do i tell her
yeah i dig your vibe too and you have a
conversation about it sort of thing
that's that's when you can decide at
that time if you're going to give up
seeing other women or if you want to
continue doing so and just letting her
know that you're not going to be
monogamous to her if that's something
that you want to do but you but you
never generally openly declare it up to
women especially early on hey i'm seeing
a bunch of other chicks right now it
needs to be uh conveyed by way of your
availability and
what's
what's basically going on in your world
right like let's say
you see this woman on a tuesday and you
got a thursday night date and she's
blowing up your phone because she wants
to talk to you you're not available you
don't respond to the text you don't
answer it because you're busy doing
something you catch up with her hey what
were you doing thursday night yeah i was
busy and you kind of move on from that
right like you don't let her know that
you had a date with nancy
right
right nancy had a great ass
you don't get any of that stuff with her
right you just carry on doing what
you're doing i mean the whole notion of
spinning plates
is ultimately i mean if you're looking
for
a girlfriend you know for example or if
you're looking at more kids
you know if that's a plan the whole
point of spinning plates is to give you
exposure to
um
everything like when you go to the
grocery store you don't just pick up one
apple and you buy it right
correct
you know you you pick up a bunch of
other apples same thing with the bananas
when you get to the bananas you pick
them up you flip them over oh those are
bruised i'm not taking those it's going
to taste like i don't want those
ones right and you kind of go through
them it's the same you know sort of
thing with dating right but you're not
going to have
a very positive successful experience if
i'm being honest if you don't go through
my book the unplugged alpha and get the
clarity that you need on looking for red
flags and understanding what really
drives attraction and arousal with women
yeah oh she's definitely aroused for
sure i mean i'm no stranger to you know
i've had plenty of experience with women
so i'm no stranger to getting women like
you know i've definitely so that's what
i'm saying i'm at a point where i've
definitely
you know uh
sampled enough women to where i know
that i'm in the point where i got it's
kind of like
they're all i'm not say all the same but
i've definitely experienced the bad ones
and i've experienced some good ones i
just want to show you some of these
comments here so nick says it's implied
not expressed okay when it comes to
dating other women simultaneously
um and mafia says being completely open
and honest about every little thing
makes you unattractive the truth of
matter is is
women want to know but they do not want
full disclosure on everything if you see
what i'm saying
you